welcome to our session
uplevel your data expertise professional
data engineer and professional ml
engineer certification
i'm doug kelly and i now oversee
learning offerings for machine learning
and ai solutions on google cloud
previously i worked as an ml engineer
and data scientist at google cloud and
oversaw data science content at coursera
i now spend my time thinking deeply
about industrializing machine learning
development on google cloud and driving
the creation of training to prepare
learners such as yourselves for data and
machine learning engineering careers
in this session i would like to start
off by discussing two key data and
machine learning challenges that
enterprises are facing today
the gap between data platform
investments and realizing value from
them
and the scarcity and corresponding high
demand for data and machine learning
engineering talent
this will frame our discussion on how
google cloud is addressing these both
through data and machine learning
platform innovations as well as through
our industry-leading professional
certifications
the professional data engineer in
professional ml engineer certifications
i hold both of these certifications and
will share my perspective with you
on the benefits of these certifications
as well as the recommended learning
paths and resources for each
lastly i will give you a preview of
what's coming next for data and machine
learning training from google cloud
learning
my goal for this session is that you
walk away excited about building data
and machine learning solutions on google
cloud and you start or level up your
learning journey towards certification
today
one of the bigger challenges for data
teams is turning into a competitive
advantage the immense fast-growing and
fast-moving amount of data that our
organizations our customers our partners
our ecosystem is creating
according to idc 175 zetabytes of data
will be created in the next five years
one zeta byte equaling one trillion
gigabytes that's 21 zeros
our data production has more than 10x in
the last eight years in fact 90 of the
data in the world has been created in
just the past 10 years
yet when it comes to turning data into
business outcomes and business value for
companies
the situation is quite alarming
over two-thirds of the data produced is
never actually analyzed and almost 70
percent of companies say they're unable
to realize
tangible and measurable value
from data
the key takeaway is this
delivering value with analytics and
machine learning requires a modern data
platform such as google cloud
data engineers are essential to build
operate and maintain these data
platforms to enable business value
and machine learning engineers
in turn build and deploy machine
learning solutions on top of a robust
data platform to drive decision making
and the realization of value
data engineers and ml engineers work
closely together on data teams to close
the data value gap by tightly
integrating data and machine learning
infrastructure
in industry we know that machine
learning has had the most business
impact by scaling real-time decision
making and personalization
that means we have to act fast to do so
we need data engineers enabling data
processing and analytic speed and ml
engineers to deliver predictions that
arrive at the point of action and real
time
that's the difference between
discovering and preventing fraud
purchases and card abandonment and
proactive and reactive customer service
google cloud is simplifying data
analytics and machine learning through
each of the platform design pillars
outlined on the slide
we deliver serverless analytics allowing
customers to keep
development velocity high in their focus
purely on analytics versus
infrastructure
we offer a comprehensive set of data
analytics workloads from batch and
streaming data processing
to data warehousing to business
intelligence
we provide the services for our
customers to operationalize machine
learning solutions from
pre-built ml apis to automl to bigquery
ml
to custom tensorflow and pytorch models
we enabled the best open source data
data technologies to give you
flexibility and choice
and we build for enterprise data and
machine learning workloads at any scale
google cloud is already an a recognized
industry leader with a purpose-built
end-to-end data analytics and machine
learning platform to support the entire
data team anywhere on premise or on
google cloud
data engineers are able to leverage
services like pub sub data flow and data
fusion to ingest prepare and transform
data at any scale
they can also leverage new data services
like dataplex and analytics sub and
market leading analytic services such as
bigquery and looker to manage and
quickly surface enterprise data sets and
insights to the entire organization
announced at google i o this year vertex
ai is also rolling out as the successor
to ai platform for machine learning
development
it provides ml engineers with an
integrated suite of services to help
enable each stage of your ml workflow
from gathering data to feature
engineering to building models and
finally deploying and monitoring these
models in production
for example new vertex mlof services
like pipelines and features store
gibbell give ml engineers
reusable ml workflows
while vertex predictions gives ml
engineers a scalable serverless solution
to get model predictions into decision
making uis faster
depending upon how you define the
machine learning market
if you look at platforms like quick labs
kaggle coursera and linkedin
there are only about 300 000 global
professional data engineers data
scientists and ml engineers today
yet at the same time there's huge demand
for data engineers and ml engineers in
the market
according to coursero market research in
just the past 12 months there's been
over 200 000 job postings requiring data
engineering and ml engineering skills
and that demand has been trending
upwards over the past three years
there's been a 91
increase in job postings requiring these
skill sets
many enterprises are still in the early
stages of data platform modernization
and ai adoption
and are really struggling to find data
engineers and ml engineers to make this
happen
to bridge the skills gap google cloud
learning has brought some of the best of
google together its top engineers
its solutions and expertise in building
large-scale data and machine learning
systems
to produce two industry-leading
certifications in the job market the
professional data engineer and
professional ml engineer
these certifications are not just about
google cloud technologies
in fact the initial
initial stages of designing each
certification are product agnostic
and just like the real world examinees
are expected to know the vast amount of
foundational concepts design patterns
and technology trade-offs that they may
encounter in their day-to-day jobs
so how these certifications been
received
by learners and recognized in the job
market
think of google cloud certifications as
valuable tools to validate your learning
and help you build your career get
promoted and earn raises
in a recent survey of google cloud
certified individuals conducted by an
independent third party we heard some
incredible pieces of feedback from
learners
across the job market on how google
cloud certifications have enabled and
boosted skills for cloud roles
78 of respondents were more confident
when talking about their future
opportunities after certification
82 of respondents felt proud to have a
proof point about their skills and
abilities when working with recruiters
83 percent of respondents told us they
felt more marketable
and finally 85 percent of respondents
just had the boost of confidence that
they both wanted and needed
to really get themselves out there for
cloud opportunities
so in short if you're asking yourself
what's in it for me i hope these
anecdotal shares and statistics drive
home how learners like yourselves have
benefited from google cloud
certifications
next let's take a look a little bit more
closely at the value propositions for
the professional data engineer and ml
engineer certifications
first let's talk about the professional
data engineer certification
a professional data engineer is the
enabler of data driven decision making
by collecting transforming and
publishing data
this is an intermediate professional
certification that requires three plus
years of industry experience and one
plus years designing and managing data
solutions on google cloud
we offer a data engineering learning
path with hands-on practice through
qwiklabs that culminates in a two-hour
multiple choice and multi-select exam to
validate your ability to design build
and operationalize data processing
systems
upon completion you earn a shareable
credential and gain access to google
cloud search
google cloud certified community swag
and events
so why do i think you should get
certified as a google cloud data
engineer
data engineering is a challenging
applied discipline that is best learned
through practice
through following the recommended
learning path you will complete 30 plus
hands-on data engineering labs in a
sandbox gcp project environment to
practice building and applying data
processing solutions
further the google cloud data engineer
certification was recently named as the
number one top paid global it
certification according to global
knowledge market research
you will learn some of the most valuable
and in-demand enterprise skills in the
market and be indispensable to
organizations modernizing their data
platforms and looking to adopt machine
learning
third you will learn data engineering
best practices from google which brought
hadoop and beam to the world and
currently processes over 2.5 exabytes of
logs per month on planet scale compute
and network
through this certification you will
differentiate yourself for career
success by learning how to choose the
right data storage and processing
services
identify the right balance of trade-offs
for various data workloads
and practice implementing production
tested data processing design patterns
to prepare you for the exam we designed
a learning path that covers foundational
data concepts and data pipeline design
patterns as well as steps you
progressively through key data ingestion
storage
and data transformation services on
google cloud
for aspiring data engineers the learning
path is designed to be completed in
about three and a half months and about
five hours per week
for existing data engineers the coursera
preparations certificate is still a
great place to start
to learn google cloud data services that
you can then supplement as needed with
additional hands-on practice through
qwiklabs
i recommend the certification to ml
engineers as well and personally started
my certification journey here first
data management and data processing are
key foundations of modern production ml
pipelines
now let's discuss the professional ml
engineer certification
this is a more advanced certification
that also recommends three plus years of
industry experience as a data scientist
or machine learning engineer
including at least one one year
designing and managing machine learning
solutions on google cloud
a professional ml engineer designs
builds and productionizes ml models to
solve business challenges using ml or
using google cloud ml services in
knowledge of proven ml
models and techniques
so why do i think you should get
certified as a google cloud ml engineer
the google cloud professional ml
engineer certification is continuously
updated by leading googler and industry
subject matter experts to best reflect
the ml engineer skill set in the job
market
this gives aspiring and current ml
engineers the opportunity to validate
their expertise in machine learning in
google cloud against a rigorous
practical industry benchmark exam
recognized in the job market
google is a globally recognized leader
in ai research in applied machine
learning with over a decade of
experience productionizing machine
learning systems is part of applications
serving billions of users per day
google cloud is the platform by which
google delivers this pioneering ml
research and product solutions to
customers
in fact google cloud's ai platform was
recognized by gartner as an industry
leader in its 2020
magic quadrant for cloud ai developer
services
my key takeaways on the ml engineer
certification for you all or this
the google cloud professional ml
engineering certification is a rewarding
learning journey for you to build your
development skills on an
industry-leading data and machine
learning platform
to both differentiate yourself as well
as position yourself for success in the
rapidly evolving field of applied
machine learning
the learning path is designed to augment
your study through a structured
progression of role-based curriculum
through google cloud fundamentals
through applied machine learning and up
to mlaps content
it's designed to be completed in about
four months at about six hours per week
the content is available on demand
through a coursera professional
certificate certificate
with additional hands-on practice
opportunities available through qwiklabs
for aspiring
ml engineers i have two additional tips
for you
first take advantage of three hundred
dollars and free credits in the google
cloud free tier on products such as the
ml apis automl and bigquery to start
building ml applications today
second learn socially and publicly
form a study group to share your
learnings and projects with others
github blogs or the google cloud
learning forms are a great place to
start
i personally like open source
contributions to projects tutorials and
documentation
take a look at open issues on some of
your favorite ml projects like
tensorflow and google cloud
samples tagged as help wanted or good
first issue as an approachable place to
dive in
lastly i'd like to share with you all
what's coming next for google cloud data
and machine learning training
it's an exciting time to developing data
and machine learning solutions so far in
2021 google cloud's already
industry-leading data and machine
learning platform has seen its most
significant enhancements in the past two
to three years
in the june 2021 data summit google
cloud engineering teams laid out their
vision for the data cloud with new
services like dataplex and analytics sub
to bring new data management and
analytic sharing capabilities to
enterprise data teams
together along with new integrations
between bigquery and looker data
engineers can focus on further breaking
down organizational data silos
to more broadly socialize insights
across organizations to enable business
value
furthermore at google i o
in may 2021
google cloud announced vertex ai as the
successor to ai platform a unification
of services such as auto ml and custom
training for developing ml solutions
faster
there are over 20 plus major updates in
net new services reaching ga
over the next year
particularly related to emma lawps
opening up fundamentally new ways to
build and deploy ml solutions and
incorporate them into decision making
systems to deliver business value
vertex ai bigquery and looker as well as
ai industry solutions empower data
scientists or data engineers and ml
engineers with new tools to close the
data value gap
while enhancing development productivity
the ability to scale your workflow and
your decision making with your data
as well as accelerating time to value
my colleagues and i in cloud learning
services are hard at work
bringing
data cloud vertex ai in industry
solutions content to you through quick
labs and coursera
stay tuned for significant new data and
machine learning training rolling out in
the second half of this year
as well as a major update to the
professional ml engineer certification
for vertex ai in the second half of 2022
now i'm keen to switch over to the
google cloud console to share with you
some of the new capabilities of vertex
ai
welcome to the vertex ai ml development
platform in the google cloud console
to get started first enable the vertex
service in the api and services tab
vertex ai is a platform that contains
services for each phase of the ml
development lifecycle
from data sets to predictions
enabling you to go from experimentation
to production ml workflows to delivering
business value faster
the data sets tab contains a list of all
of your data sets in your project
with support for image tabular text and
video data types
manage data sets enable you to create a
link between your data sets and your
models for traceable and reproducible
experiments
you also get descriptive statistics on
your data set
as well as
the ability to configure automatic or
custom data splitting
the notebooks tab contains new features
such as manage vertex notebooks
vertex notebooks are interactive jupiter
lab development environments that enable
you to quickly build custom machine
learning solutions
they provide support for multiple
frameworks flexible compute
and easy access to accelerators like
gpus and tpus
they also have newer tighter
integrations with key google cloud data
services
like cloud storage
and bigquery
in a single window
check out some of the newer integrations
with dataproc as well which also makes
vertex notebooks a great single window
for development of apache spark as well
in the training tab
you can also see and create your
training pipelines
using the same managed data set
for both automl and custom training jobs
you can leverage pre-built containers
with your model code with frameworks
like tensorflow scikit-learn pytorch or
xgboost
for maximal flexibility you can also
leverage custom containers as well
leverage in any framework you'd like
with any additional dependencies
upload it to artifact registry and use
it for model training prediction or as a
pipeline step
automl is a great way
to quickly build highly accurate models
with built-in support for standard
evaluation metrics
feature attributions
quick model deployment
as well as metadata that covers the
model architecture search as well as the
hyper parameters that were searched as
well
in the experiments tab you can create a
managed tensorboard instance
to organize and compare model
performance across model runs and data
splits
for predictions you can deploy new
endpoints for online predictions
or schedule batch jobs for both bulk
predictions as well
a model can be deployed to multiple
endpoints or can serve multiple models
on a single endpoint
with multiple models on a single
endpoint and traffic splitting
capabilities you now have some new model
prediction evaluation capabilities such
as a b testing
for production ml workflows the new
vertex pipeline service enables you to
automate monitor and govern your machine
learning systems by orchestrating your
tasks in a serverless manner
clicking into an individual pipeline run
you have a graphical user interface to
view and debug each step of your
workflow from data set creation
model training evaluation and deployment
you can expand upon your artifacts to be
able to deep dive into individual
pipeline runs
and there are artifacts such as model
evaluation metrics
in this example you also have a
conditional model deployment step
which you can use to ensure that you're
only pushing higher performing models to
production
this concludes a quick walkthrough of
just some of the new features available
in vertex ai i encourage you to also
check out services
like data labeling
ml metadata for tracking your
development artifacts across your
project as well as the upcoming feature
store which enables you to reuse
features across ml use cases
for hands-on practice in a google cloud
project with some of the features i just
introduced check out the vertex ai labs
on qwiklabs
a great place to start is the vertex ai
quick start
where you will walk through an
end-to-end custom training workflow on
vertex ai to train and deploy
a tensorflow model to predict customer
lifetime value
to start your data and machine learning
engineering learning journeys today
check out our recently launched google
cloud skills boost our new destination
for google cloud learning with over 700
labs and courses
this will be available to you all the
entire month of october free of charge
it's never been a more exciting and
productive time to be building data
systems and doing applied machine
learning
thank you for learning with us